En.. en.. encore une journée, de plus à supporter. L'apréhention d'affronter ces gens qui vont m'dévisager. Depuis tout p'tit c'est comme ça tout le monde tourne la tête pour me voir, tous les regards s'posent sur moi comme un rat dans un laboratoire. Je.. je suis comme Moïse, comme la mer rouge, la foule s'divise. La solitude me suit comme marquée au fer rouge à vie. Qu'est-c'qui n'tourne pas rond, pourquoi ne suis-je pas comme tout le monde..
Tu veux que j'te réponde ?
C'est parce que... Tu t'habilles comme une merde !
Les chaussettes dans les sandales c'est interdis par la loi. Comme une merde ! Quand tu te poses sur banc, tu récoltes de l'argent. Comme une merde ! Quand tu vas chez Emmaüs, on t'refuse tes vêtements.
Comme une merde ! Même une merde s'habille mieux toi.. Tu t'habilles comme une merde ! Si Lidl faisait des fringues, tu en porterais. Comme une merde !
Une seule solution : ton armoire doit brûler. Comme une merde ! Comme une merde.. merde.. merde..
Je crois.. je crois.. je crois que j'ai compris. J'ai retenue la leçon. J'ai jeté tous mes habits, j'vais faire attention pour de bon. J'ai claqué mes économies dans des produits hors de prix mais le regard des gens reste identique..
Faut qu'j't'explique.. Tu t'habilles comme une merde !
J'sais pas comment t'as fait mais c'est pire qu'avant. Comme une merde ! Ton swag est négatif, c'est consternant. Comme une merde !
Désolé c'est pas la peine de passer le casting. Comme une merde ! Pour une émission de relooking..
Cette situation m'ronge, c'est terminé je jette l'éponge. J'sortirais pas d'cette impasse..
Attends mec.. euh, qu'est-c'qui s'passe là.. Tu t'habilles comme une merde ! Mais t'es tellement différent que t'es devenu tendance. Comme une merde ! Mais on dit qu't'as un temps d'avance. Comme une merde !
Baby attends-moi dans 5 ans.
Comme une merde !
J'ai changé d'la merde en argent.
Tu t'habilles comme une merde !
J'm'habille comme une merde. J'pique les yeux, sa mère.
Comme une merde !
"Tas d'arpèche", j'prend la relève.
Tu t'habilles comme une merde !